hello hello it's week 11 week 12 I don't
know but I got Sims and he got Flo and
my name is Adam week 10 left week 10
you're off on you know it's week we're
going into week 11 yeah we're talking
about we're talking about the bee Japan
is not over yet we got the greatest game
of all time scheduled for tonight
Giants Niner hats we are recording this
on Monday hey you know what's actually
funny someone said that's I think it was
actually Nick eg he goes oh yeah real
great game two combined wins between the
Giants and nine or as I said this is
another Sims and left go Superbowl
it is Odell Beckham jr. right alight us
right taking on Kyle Shanahan and the
new legend Nick Mullens oh one thing I
noticed when I had to talk to San
Francisco like media this week they're
all like super excited to see Collins
shake while Barkley why are they excited
they just you know what do we expect we
haven't really got a taste of him yet
and that's what se Kwang's doing though
he's making a name for himself where
people are like actually excited to go
like man Odell Beckham jr. but we
haven't seen this sake one yet Josh I'm
sorry a run down this happens all the
time
is is sake one number Rookie of the Year
is Phillip Lindsey is Baker Mayfield
Offensive Rick I would go a say quad
nobody has been more impressive than say
Kwan making more out of less that's what
I do it's what I look at more than
anything the short throws at one yard
down the field
I feel like Baker is getting a lot I
feel like he's won a lot of the rookie
Offensive Player of the weeks
yeah and he's really the only
quarterback that is consistently
performing right by level right and
again had to fight that narrative - I
mean that the early last week it was or
should we be panicked about Baker
Mayfield I mean it's just constant with
this quarterback thing well I think it's
constant I think one thing that I've
learned covering the NFL is that every
week people freak out yeah and I saw
that with the Sunday Night Football game
Eagles and Cowboys last week Cowboys
lose to the Titans and every show that I
turn on is going the Cowboys are a
dumpster fire should Jason Garrett be
clapped what's gonna happen to this
franchise Jerry Jones says extend dak
and it's like wow and then this morning
I'm in the office yeah and the
meeting and I'm not listening because
I'm watching the television because I
have a problem it's called a DD and I
look up and I see are the Cowboys
secretly dangerous can the Cowboys win
the East and I'm going guys it's been
one week their issues are still the same
yeah their strengths are still the same
right nothing's changed it's it's every
we every year we do this and it's a it's
only the NFL cuz it's a week-to-week
thing but you know we try to be sane and
we try to step back all right it is it
drives me crazy it's the number one
thing we need to fight against it's
overreaction or stupid takes that are
just leading a false narrative
have you heard anything today or
yesterday kind of in the weeds today
yeah I don't even know what the hell I
don't know if anything's there no I
can't say that there's anything that's
jumped out to me yeah do you ever watch
games at home and see something and
start fake arguments with yourself
we're like true Biscay throws a pass oh
you can't throw that in my brain I mean
like went through the interception on
the first try I was like we said can't
beat yourself Eagles it's like
Jacksonville's gotta do the same thing i
mean yeah i always have conversations
that's how i can emotionally invest it
in games yes you have to yes oh I was
getting so angry at Philadelphia at
Twitter before we get into that game
Thanksgiving week schedule this is for
next week we're only gonna have two
podcasts okay one is gonna be Tuesday
a.m. right and that is gonna be
recapping everything that happened this
upcoming week 11 yeah and then the other
one is going to come out Thursday a.m.
right and that's gonna be a combination
of the bedding podcast and since you're
gonna watch film right I think the
notion is if we get into a game and
we're doing the bedding yeah and you
have a film nugget that you want to drop
we'll weave it in like okay that's cool
I like that I like that so we're gonna
do two next way to go way to quarterback
that thing kid Josh and I sat down in a
room he was my who's the new offensive
coordinator for the Browns Freddie
kitchen he used my Freddie kitchens I'm
Baker feel a little dangerous Oh a
little dangerous that's funny in his in
my ear right now he just buttered it and
said he basically just told you what to
do so he's he said I'm Baker Mayfield
I get all the credit Freddie kitchens in
the back being like I mean I'm the one
calling the screens I'm the one calling
big tight end formation right yeah
credit the Baker yeah
Sims and left go football fantasy league
SL FL Sims I'm an affiliate in yes it
was a very big game for us emotionally
and physically imagine an NFL team
traded with another NFL team and then
all those stars faced off yes the guy
that we traded with oh gee spleen buster
right which was the name of the
marijuana stream and he talked about we
faced him and we won what it hood up
were up were up 14 and we got another
person to play we still have Odell
tonight unless hotel gets negative 14 oh
if we want to recap the trade yeah I
would like to recap let's let's give it
to oh geez lien Buster Morgan I
appreciate you oh geez please message it
your name - uh we traded to him Adam
Thielen latavius Murray Devonta Freeman
and Peyton Barbour right and we got back
Aaron Rodgers Tyriq Hill Tariq Cohen and
Jameson Crowder - so three of our guys
that sounds like an inside deal that
sound did you pay him off it wasn't it
wasn't he had another quarterback we
desperately needed one you wouldn't let
me play Blake bortles right and Tariq
Cohen just started popping off and
Devonta Freeman got hurt damn yeah yeah
just it didn't look good from the outset
but of all the players he probably got
the most reliable and feelin but I will
say looking at our record right now Sims
I know you don't understand fantasy at
all 3 7 & 3 we are currently we're going
to be 6 and 4 after this weekend putting
us right at the top with some of the
other were the top of our division and
it's getting ready for playoffs what's
the name of our division again art oh
it's actually a funny one - beans not
beef at the hell are we know so we're in
the golden spleen conference ok but our
division is that so Lance which is the
guy that I went to the funeral and
remember Lance that story and then the
other the other division is big barb
which is your grand mom and my grandma
the big barb division egg farm yeah
shout out to meatloaf meat hen for
making thank you
yeah thanks for the shoutout you Harbor
do you know when the fantasy football
playoffs start I know it's soon I know
it's like I want to say like week 14 way
to go thanks man
14:15 and usually championships are week
16 okay
which is why Dover well that's why a lot
of fantasy guys right now is it good to
have Todd Gurley because what if they
start resting on that's why Patriots
right
owning Patriots was always tough yes cuz
you go Tom Brady at that point of the
year what's gonna happen right that's
why I'm kind of thinking about picking
little Spencer where well that's why for
the Rams if you got Rams players you
just root for the Saints that's all you
got to do you got a root for the same
that's it well no as long as they have
to play for the one seed they're gonna
continue to play they're gonna try to
play that day or much rather have the
Saints come to them and them go to the
Saints so I saw a picture of you in
South Bend yeah you looked so cold no
gloves
I saw your pen waving around I had the
gloves on until we went onto TV and then
I would throw them away because if I
wanted to write something down on it or
through a page it's hard to do that with
gloves I feel like a Notre Dame game in
the cold in South Bend that was pretty
special it's the way footballs supposed
to be because when I think of Rudy right
I think of people clapping with mittens
and hats and heavy jackets on yeah yeah
exactly
I know and it's nothing to those people
out there Notre Dame was not affected at
all by the weather was bundling up
before they ran out to warm up so it was
hilarious to watch action does the cold
impact and if college players more than
NFL player yes it does because the NFL
at some point or another you're gonna
get a taste of it College you could play
at the University of Florida never play
a cold game for four years how long does
it take those players to adjust in the
NFL a while you know like I said I've
had games in the NFL where we had my
Tampa team had a bunch of Florida guys
on the team and we went in the locker
room one of the games is against
Jacksonville like in mid-november to
happen to be cold up in Jacksonville and
yes it was there now used to it cuz no
other way to say it when carry on
Johnson had that huge game against Miami
he talked about how great it was to be
back in the heap sure and then when I
was watching the game yesterday and he
had that fumble I was like yeah I'm
almost positive that you
I used to the cold weather right and
then somebody comes in and punches the
balls my issue with the college football
playoff it's always on the southern
teams format it's always on that like
I'd like how do you think Alabama would
have to apply if that to go play cold
Michigan and in January instead of
Michigan having to go playing some warm
weather climate where they're gonna have
to play Alabama on their site their
terms I know what Alabama is awesome but
I met Sims we don't want to let mother
nature dictate I know but you know those
teams have to build for that all year
they have to build fir we got Michigan
State and all of a sudden yeah it's a
speed game that's I always thought that
is a little unfair to the college
football you know northern big ten type
team Alabama winning at all this year
certainly seems like it I do think
Michigan give them a tough time really
yeah Michigan's Deacon thought Michigan
was dead a few weeks ago Michigan's D is
the best d in college football they got
some right they can muck it up and they
have enough offense but you know I could
that's the only way I could see it being
upset
I think Notre Dame could beat Clemson
and round one wrong I do yeah I mean
Notre Dame's as good as anybody other
than you know Alabama kind of I'm just
glad that you cover college football so
that you're more prepared for the
traffic is that it really I like it
Eagles Cowboy Sunday Night Football the
Adam left go panic meter from one to ten
is now at a six point seven five seven
five I am not officially panicking but
I'm looking at the rest of the NFC and
I'm going it is a cluster and the only
way they're getting in is if they win
the East
yeah the good thing is I look at
Washington and I go I don't think this
is gonna continue right I look at the
Cowboys and I go damn I did pick them to
win the division before the year and now
they have a half a game lead up but
right I don't know how consistent the
Cowboys are gonna be but losing Ronald
Darby for the year is a killer killer I
mean with jaylen mills and Sydney Jones
already being out ya know it's I don't
know what else to say your secondary
wasn't that great to begin with and they
had already lost rowdy McCloud so yes
exactly right yeah you know I think
about you a few times this year with the
Eagles cuz of one Proclamation you made
before the year the fact that you guys
kind of escaped the injury bug last year
now we're just getting injured to all
the other players it didn't get
you're right and you kind of said like
you know last year we kind of escaped it
I know you had the when's and the Jason
Peters but you're like as a whole you
did and one no no but at the same time
they lost Jordan Hicks yeah I lost Darby
for eight weeks they they had lost a lot
of injuries they lost their kicker but
my thing was more they survived all
those like all those injuries and they
still did it right but last night was
also proof if you don't have Lane
Johnson it's such a bigger loss than a
Jason Peters right but you watch that
game and then do you do you come away
confident in the Cowboys no I don't come
I came away feeling exactly the same
about the Cowboys and feeling a little
bit worse about the Eagles I came away
going I still don't know what Jim
Schwartz is doing with this defense no I
mean the yeah my first issue would be
the third and 15 third and long defenses
where we're gonna play seven guys at the
yard marker and then rally to tackle I
mean if any other teams do that a few
here and there but not real it's just
not I know the good defenses do that I
can tell you that my thing for Eagles
fans would go when you watch the Cowboys
yeah all of their big plays are when
they do something short and set up
blockers so why would you put all of
your guys 15 yards away and let two
offensive linemen run in front of Zeke
I'm fine with them dak trying to throw a
post corner to a more ecoo per yeah I'm
fine with that dak load up take a shot
right but the screen that's the one
thing I'm afraid of what the Cowboys
screen that was the changing the the
moment of jump over that guy's head well
I mean for that them to get the first
down and it's six three football game
and then they go down to make it 13 to
three-and-a-half like if it just goes 9
to 3 and a half I still feel like you
guys are gonna win the football game 6
to foot 10 to 3 changed it I mean that
13 to 3 yeah 13 to 3 I mean yes I change
it Leighton van Dhiresh yeah are we
gonna sell Scout sure or did Chris
Collinsworth just get way too excited
because Cory Clement is wildly overrated
at this point and doesn't have another
gear yeah no there's no well that that's
that's his game as long as he can go
sideline to sideline and be an athlete
he's great krei on the goal line
right but I gotta see more of that I
mean that would be like one of the only
times I've seen him still square
somebody up my issue with him is when it
gets to when they play the New Orleans
Saints the first time or somebody like
that where it's downhill run that's
where I really questioned him at Boise
State to be kind of that Smash Mouth
middle line better again as long as the
speed athlete game he's he is top-notch
as you know yeah I know that the Eagles
have a sick fascination with going
outside it's stupid it's like you guys
think you got speed running back what
about Jaylon Smith right where's he at
now Jaylon Smith has been really damn
good Chris Collinsworth was like we got
a new regime of linebackers here and
down yeah I mean it is he's I was still
not to where he was and he's real good
but I just before I say that too to
understand when I say he's not where he
was like he had a chance to be the best
middle linebacker in football from year
one that's how awesome he was in college
football yeah like when I turned on the
film I knew this was the one of the top
defensive guys in the draft and I turned
it on and I was like holy [ __ ] he's
unbelievable like that's how great he
was he was a bona fide top five Rueben
foster everybody talked about him being
tight his film couldn't compete with
Jalen Smith's that's how awesome he was
so if he's like 80% of that it's still
which he's getting close to there yeah
yeah he is 80% of that maybe 90 now
DeMarcus Lawrence was fantastic
defensive line got some pressure but man
watching the Cowboys their offense you
know I mean the Eagles quarterbacks just
couldn't even stop a slant no so I think
Dallas had opportunities in that game
that they're not gonna be able to do
against many other defenses I would say
that well and the other thing too is you
know I the thing that I'll take away
from the game more than anything I just
in a hundred years wouldn't have thought
they would gas you guys in the run game
the way they did that was where I just
was like what man I mean they're a gash
in you in the run game backside cut
backs that are do you think it was
because they dominated time of
possession in the first half and just
warm down I think that's certainly just
part of offense could you go first down
and to me it looked like some
undisciplined run fits on the back side
but I you know again I'll give you a
better feel for that on Thursday for
that podcast when I get to break down
the
but yet that and what that led to a lot
of the times to with the run game stuff
is you know hey we saw ya Mari Cooper
didn't blow up the stat sheet but but he
showed that he's effective and if you're
gonna leave him man-to-man he's
incredibly hard to cover yeah he's a
great round runner and they kind of got
his mojo going right now
I am so down on deck yeah I just don't
see it round there's nothing to see your
your eyes right your eye is like mulai
wide open out routes yes like running
there's a guy they can't even hit that
it's it's extremely inconsistent below
average NFL starting quarterback
standard mechanics yes the Macan what do
you see like that's blatant yeah I mean
the thing I see that blatant is you know
he what happens to a lot of guys it's
the arm independent contractor thing
more more than not where he's wrong he
gets affront throws in front shoulder
just tries to muscle it over the top oh
like and that's you know again you know
and you might listen to me enough you
shouldn't ever be thinking over the top
you should be thinking around as a
thrower Brady and Rogers and the good
throwers are thinking yes exactly right
come around to the opposite breast yes
your follow-through it's that more than
anything you know
and yeah the ball just does not come out
of his hand clean that way and he
compromises his power with that in Bude
than in it as well hmm
so it's it's all those hey other thing
we got to do about that game too you
know it's what will me just figure this
out what was the score at the time it's
six to three
oh no not that one thirty no I want to
still not that one hold on I got notes
that I Tex just tell me where it was
yeah oh you don't get the fourth and one
right you stop the Cowboys yes
I just wanna we got to give credit where
credit's to and they call a fake punt
yeah and extend the tribe yeah and get a
field goal yeah good job Jason Garrett
yeah just say you're right you're right
you're just trying to give him a little
credit there if that was a big time call
kind of changed like the momentum a
little bit where there was like damn we
got a turnover stopped on downs oh [ __ ]
nothing happened okay here we go
right kept your defense on the field
like a little longer again to continue
that we're down factor the worst part
the worst part it was Jeff Heath yeah
he's such a killer right he's the one
that a touchdown at a field Jeff Heath
was the one that tackled
Hertz on that fourth and seven - right
Jeff Heath Jeff Heath my supreme he's
fast yes he's done well alright but I
still think the Eagles have a chance to
the playoffs right now they're four and
five I think they can finish nine and
seven if they sweep Washington beat
Dallas beat the Giants beat Houston
listen to Washington schedule I think
they could lose a lot of bacon they can
lose the Houston Texans this week yeah
they can lose that they got the Cowboys
to begin to that could lose that have
that they got the Eagles could lose that
they got the Giants I'm gonna say it's a
win it's a win but it ain't easy I mean
they barely meet the Giants two weeks
ago then they got a go to Jacksonville
could be a loss then they got to go to
the Tennessee Titans yeah and then they
got you guys again yeah that's what I'm
saying
so I know yeah I mean you you could win
the dim and I've ceased at eight nape
this year they go three and three it's
not only go five and two right sweep
them right I got a chin yeah so it's not
over yet but we did say I'm not gonna
say I told you so yet that the Cowboys
were gonna win the division but it is
kind of lining up pretty good yeah it
doesn't feel like it's gonna be a win if
they win all I know is whoever will win
by default
for whoever wins that division they're
out in the first run because we both
picked them okay Patriots Titans it is
now so official that it's not even close
and the writing is on the wall right
right right right where are you going
October 11th 2009 Denver 20 New England
17 Josh McDaniels gets a big win over
Bill Belichick confidence is reigning hi
yep I was there September 23rd 2018 New
England loses by 16 to mat Patricia
amongst swirling rumors that he had lost
the roster not only that but also GM Bob
Quinn yeah November 11th 2018 New
England loses by 24 points to former
player Mike Vrabel yeah and former front
office member of the Patriots John
Robinson Belichick is allowing his
former Protege x' that he really likes
to gain confidence and to allow them to
have a win over the esteem
balichek the only person that's not
beaten balichek is Bill O'Brien yeah
Whittle O'Brien's over five and you know
what cause I don't think Bill Belichick
thinks Bill O'Brien Isabella cheque guy
I really think Bill Belichick looks at
Bill O'Brien and goes you were in one of
mine you were here for a short amount of
time you're not me
you're not Josh you're not Mike that's
what he's saying what this means though
is if you look you're going from an
offensive coordinator defensive
coordinator player it keeps going down
right you know what the next one is tape
guy okay well you know our Sims had new
head coach of the New York Jets gonna
win other thing you're gonna look at too
is Dean pees on the Tennessee Titans
staff too who was also in New England so
I did not know that Dean
oh yeah it was a Baltimore no he was
before Baltimore he was New England so
like when the New England in 2007 was
undefeated they lead that year that was
Dean pieces the defensive guy that year
yeah so that adds to what we saw
yesterday
is there any obviously my conspiracy
theory is not true he's not I don't
write he's actively doing that now of
course then but what it's interesting
that he's lost he's oh and three yeah
those guys say one know what it takes to
beat them as far as the coach verse
coach competition thing right the other
thing I think just just a general
comment about the whole thing is those
guys understand situational football
they understand more importantly what
the Patriots want to do in situational
football and the little what I would
just call [ __ ] things that the
Patriots do to give themselves an
advantage yes as like we're gonna get to
my notes here in a second but one of the
biggest [ __ ] things they took away
there was no [ __ ] screen game
yesterday for the Patriots no wide
receiver screens to set up second and
one or ad no running back screens none
of that happened yesterday so there was
one phase that they took away just right
off the bat where they said okay hey you
might hit us with some deep crossers and
things like this
but we're not gonna let these behind the
line of scrimmage passes gaseous
consistently through the game to make
first and ten first and ten again yeah
or to make first and 15 go to second
- and you still get the first down first
thing you wrote in your notes right not
sure if I've ever seen three a 15 on
third down and only 284 total yards and
I would say it's not just what they did
on 3rd down yeah
the Titans set them up for long 3rd down
right 1st and 2nd right by stopping the
little guineas yes
the Patriots a little dump off the James
White Oh a little run up here now it's
third and 2 exactly they were in 3rd and
7 3rd and 8th almost the whole game and
no doubt they won 1st and 2nd down to
give themselves a chance to win on there
they do anything that other teams don't
do they did they did I would say like
New England they did it they changed
looks right to confuse Brady made it
look like you know we're gonna blitz but
we dropped out you know how I always
talking about blitz zone change right
where they would have two defensive
tackles on the outside edge of the
guards right ok on the outside shoulders
of the guards and the two middle
linebackers would cross blitz up the
middle and the two deepens ends would
drop out and the 2 D tackles were on the
outside shoulders of the guards they
would replace the D ends so it becomes a
four-man rush but it's a different look
that's confusing and Plus Shaq Mason
didn't play and Trent Brown only played
50 right so they test the dad out so why
can every team do that everybody can yes
but not everybody can coach it to the
sound capabilities that some of these
really good intelligent coaches can do
whether that's a variable and appease or
and when you say sound you've said this
before yeah is it they know exactly
where on the guard you should attack is
it the lane integrity like also not
being like oh we're taking a chance over
here but we're totally gonna forget
about here they don't forget about
anything they still say yeah we're gonna
do this but we still have to eat a guy
for each gap in the run game we're not
just gonna like roll the dice and be
like I hope I hit lucky 7 cuz if they
run to the left here it's gonna be a 40
yard gain no everybody's in a right
place schematically still to where it
gets to a sound defense they just it's
window dressing like a good offensive
coordinator you know that and they had a
knowledge of what you and I talked about
a million times when you play New
England they took away the area's New
England likes to throw you already
mentioned at the back out of the
backfield the dump off in the middle all
those short things that he was
thrown deeper he was seen because that's
all they had was deep crossing deep
crossers and he tried to hit some
one-on-ones with Josh Gordon they tried
a few trick plays yep I knew wrote stay
disciplined yeah you underlined it a few
times right what did you see that was
different from how other teams get
fooled they just you know they tried to
do the fake run up the middle fake
reverse right and then all we're gonna
throw Josh Gordon over the top for a big
post play no they were all over it they
were just like I got man-to-man the
safety was deep and he just said I have
no run responsibilities I my eye is
gonna stay on Josh Gordon I've seen this
story before you know that's where Dean
Pease and Mike Vrabel came into play
we're just you know again it's kind of
New England he'd do your job
we know you have to be ready for these
trick plays and nobody kind of went
outside of their realm of
responsibilities to where they expose
themselves the key you've always said
about the Patriots is rush a little drop
a lot yes you said you wrote here
kamal korea who they traded with with
baltimore before the year yeah Harold
Landry the second-round pick that many
thought would have been a top 15 pick
right and then Evans the middle
linebacker out of Alabama they traded a
head of the Patriots to take because
they thought the Patriots won you said
all those guys popped off the field I
didn't even know Evans was a pastor oh I
know
but Evans does a little bit of that like
Dante Hightower role where you know he's
a middle linebacker before exactly right
it's sometimes they just go hey it's
third down you play outside there and
you rush and he's got rushing skills
just like Dante Hightower he's that was
a big of a man at Alabama but he's quick
as hell and he's got power and he's got
a spin move and knows how to use his
hands and he's advanced that way because
he went to Alabama and he's already
learned those things from Nick Saban I
am so confused by the Titans yeah I mean
yeah that game against Baltimore when
they got shutout in their offensive line
got decimated right they've had a few
other duds this year but now the Dallas
game and this game do you believe that
they found their defensive identity yes
I feel like their defense has never been
that big of an issue okay and more we're
finally seeing their offense get to
their identity I think more than
anything over the last where we get to
their offense I like when you write down
a guy that we don't spotlight enough
right this is a guy that led the NFL in
interceptions last year and I'd I still
don't think it's mention of he does not
fired yeah Kevin Baier it is all over
the place him and Kenny Vaccaro both
played really well but by yard yes
whether it's the run game and how
quickly he can fill the hole isn't Kenny
Vaccaro and I are know he was out there
yesterday who did they lose before the
year oh he was the replace he was the
replacement to hold on uh was it was it
C or C who the hell was there's other
safety I can't even think oh look at UPS
but either way they were both good but
yes by art is one of the most complete
Cyprian Cyprian jonathan safran he's one
of the most complete safeties in the
sport there's really no weakness to his
game like I'm not gonna say he's as good
as Jamal Adams when he's down in the box
having to do that but he's not far off
I'm not gonna say he's the best coverage
safety in football but he's not far off
he's really a complete football player
that yeah they can leave a man-to-man on
back some tight ends and he holds his
own and his read and react skills in the
run game are amazing you gave me two
stars on the back page yeah Mike buck
cross de drops were huge that's like
what I was talking about just before
with the cross the D tackles rush and
the d-ends dropped out right so it's
still a four-man rush but it looks like
pressure and it tests the offensive
lines ability to pass things off and
communicate that way and with no shock
Mason and Trent Brown not being on the
practice to do those things during the
week they took advantage of that there
was nearly eight minutes left right and
Brady came out of the game right what
did you think about that I they said
that's enough that's enough Brady's been
getting hit too much
they got us today their game plans
phenomenal it was only a three score
game but I think they just realized that
they didn't want Brady to take any more
hits and they were gonna move on and
just take the yell and go from there and
did you like that I had no problem with
it I felt like there was no way they
were gonna get control of that game
again you know the other the the the
three guys on the outside Malcolm Butler
Logan Ryan and a Dori Jackson especially
a Dori Jackson played phenomenal but
they did good jobs when they had a play
man-to-man in certain spots Logan Ryan
shutdown Edelman a few times over the
middle
some man situations Dorie Jackson made
life very hard for Josh Gordon I mean he
just he stayed in his back hit and
basically said I'm gonna play for the
back shoulder ball and I don't think you
can run by me and he is very good ball
skills that's where he's special I would
argue that not many people don't run by
our door know exactly right and you know
Gordon is Gordon's become almost like
Gronk for them that's what he's doing
with that it's it's if it's a big play
Brady just goes screw everybody else
it's one-on-one with Gordon doesn't
surprise you it surprised me that that's
happened this quick it doesn't surprise
me if you saw the size of Josh Gordon
when you see him in person it's a
comfort blank it is a comfort bunny and
he dropped a few yesterday that it
usually doesn't drop he had one back
shoulder go through his hands he dropped
a slant maybe in the first quarter at
one point but yeah those those how was
one outcome Butler because mal Malcolm
Butler has been getting yeah by people
yeah no Malcolm Butler was very good
even him he had a few plays just here
and there maybe only two plays with Josh
Gordon but he didn't gamble on anything
during the football game I think that
was the big thing I took away from Moore
that's has been his biggest issue he
just been gambling he's been too over
aggressive alright so now let's go the
offense of the Titans because I think
anyone that saw the highlights yesterday
it was Mariota deep fade Corey Davis
Corey Davis has games against the Eagles
and Patriots where I go he's a top 10
wide receiver yes League right and then
there's other games where he can't even
get off a block on a jam yeah this was
the good Corey Dave it was the good
Corey Davis you wrote here Mariota
throwing ball as pure as I have ever
seen ever I mean the ball came out of
his hand clean all day long and really
the first drive of the game he's run ZUP
in the pocket and hits Corey Davis on
the end cut like on the run he throws it
and it just I mean I was just like damn
who is that guy throwing the ball so
natural where the hell you've been the
last three years and it continued
throughout the game and he threw every
ball exactly where he wanted to he
really didn't miss a target all day long
it's two weeks in a row he's really
striped the ball pretty good too makes
me think he's comfortable he's
comfortable with the offense they have
found the formula finally that they like
on that side of the ball and they
haven't made everything so hard on him I
mean
they had a good game plan yesterday what
they did they expose some of the
Patriots rules on defense they made sure
okay you want to play man-to-man well
we're gonna let Corey Davis be
man-to-man on Stephon Gilmore we like
our matchup but it's gonna be in the
middle of the field it's not gonna be on
the boundary so Gilmore can use the
boundary they got them in some Bunch
sets and then basically you saw some of
those deep out routes he caught right or
the go route down the left sideline I
mean Gilmore was hanging on if the gray
just be like he beat me I got a tackle
me they basically went and this is gonna
come up again they cone the bunch okay
this will come up with the Bears game
when we get to that they cone the bunch
and when I say they bunch so think of a
bunch of receiver set with three guys
right they the point man plays the point
man so there's the guy in front of that
bunch
he's man-to-man and that guy's got him
no matter what and then the other two
basically just go I got the first guy
that comes inside I got the first guy
that comes outside right and Davis was
the inside guy the outside guy would go
outside so we got that
but Davis was the inside guy now to come
up on Gilmore and basically have a
two-way go to go we can go across the
field or he can run a deep out either
way and Gilmore is in a tough spot cuz
he's got to cover a man-to-man against
freaky athlete and there's 40 yards of
grass to cover him on and you're just
not gonna do that and then Mariota made
those throws and you wrote Corey Davis I
was wrong yeah I was wrong I didn't
think he can ever be I don't think Corey
Davis is a top-10 receiver but he is
really good he's a really good route
runner his body control is phenomenal
and he has enough speed to scare the
Stephon Gilmore the world to where they
can't just sit on them all again he can
really high point him he really can he's
very impressive I was wrong on that one
sorry John Robinson you the man and you
said man Gilmore they ask a lot of him
every week in another shitty NFL field
that another shitty NFL field but I do
again that that has to be talked about
with Gilmore you know again I why does
nobody get on Gilmore like Marcus Peters
last week you know again he lit up seven
catches for 125 you got torched he's
horrible it torched yeah oh I just said
to me I don't understand why does that
conversation not happen this week but it
happens is Marcus Peters well I would
also argue the Gillman that week Gilmore
just had a fantastic week to week
screaming bad okay that's a good point
you're right Gilmore's awesome I'm not
trying to say anything
what Gilmore is asked to do and one was
a one o'clock game and the other one was
a four o'clock big time game yeah I
think you're right okay but yeah Gilmore
is awesome what he is asked to do again
I don't know if anybody's asked to play
on an island against number one
receivers more on a weekly basis than
Stephon Gilmore they make him earn every
dollar of his contract and he does and
their success of their defense is
because of what he does but yet they
made life hard on him on Tennessee with
some of their formations and schemes to
go okay you want to do this we're gonna
make it really hard on you and we like
our guy to Titans are five and four yeah
I know is this thing gonna keep rolling
I would think so I would say Mariota is
throwing right now Derek Henry looks
like he's got a little bit more juice in
his step the last few weeks they needn't
even have Conklin yesterday I know they
were fine I know they were they they you
just told me that they got the pass
rushers we know they got three corners
they got a safety that you just said can
do anything yeah and their linebackers
are athletic III listen there's no I
like and you like what Vrabel and Dean
peas are doing and what about Lafleur
yeah I the floor is the one that's
finally changed to me yes just with you
know his overall play calling tying
plays together finding little easy ways
to get completions I feel like that's
what it's taken off here just recently
the sequencing the sequencing is more
than anything
and of course pass protection and not
asking guys to do unrealistic things Hey
they they did first down screens
creative first down runs to keep them in
second and fourth yes you know like I
wrote I wrote Tennessee out in New
England New England in Tennessee yeah I
mean you know one of those guys that did
it Dion Lewis his comments after the
game hell yeah it was personal that's
what happens when you go cheap you get
you ass kicked
yeah would you like that I did like that
yes I mean it's funny because New
England went cheap before and relied on
Dion Lewis yeah right right he was the
first he popped yeah yeah yeah but that
was when nobody wanted I'm gonna get a
did you know knee issue and all that but
that's the that's New England Falls and
when New England scheme
can't give them the big advantage there
every half-elves dieter over all D right
everyone FL player at the Super Bowl
last year from Melvin Gordon to Kareem
hunt they all said we're a better team
than New England yes the players they
have better coaches right he good they
uh it was almost like they were
embarrassed like dude if we walked on
the field we'd look at them ago we're
gonna kick their ass it's a lot a lot of
teams do they just fight so I have a few
conspiracy phrase one the he's letting
his former guys get wins right to
Belichick knows he's fine let's get a
loss heading into the bye week to get my
team super focused for the run now I
have things I can yell about for about
two weeks and I think three and I think
my favorite Belichick conspiracy they
are so good in Foxborough and they're
not that great on the road this year
yeah they're really not that great on
the road a lot of years but this year
especially got blown out in Detroit got
blown out in Tennessee Chicago allowed
like 31 points sure Bob Malone wasn't
beautiful Buffalo wasn't beautiful in
fact they were up nine to six at one
point or whatever you have said to me
before that when Baltimore goes to New
England they're so paranoid that they
bring their own trash bags yeah because
when they shred things up and throw them
away they think that New England will go
through the tray usually scan the locker
room like you know equipment scanners
like the Ravens yeah because they were
looking for bugs they think they're
being bugged all of us that's my
favorite Patriots conspiracy they got a
line listening to your play calls they
they all occasionally like you ever see
someone playing in Foxborough they're
going like this oh yeah they call them
that scrambling somebody scrambling up
right I know there's anything that I
think could be the most conspiracy
theory that could be the most accurate
right is that you go to Foxborough and
everything is against you yeah I only
get the spanish-speaking announcers on
the replay right para los Panthers
you get to the stadium late cuz there's
only one highway in and the bus can't go
in that way you gotta go through some
neighborhood at all and there's some
lady on the street faking a heart attack
that's what it's for balichek yeah I
think it's all possible
but overall you came away and it sounds
just reading your notes it sounds like
everything that you said about variable
and peas no one what to expect yeah it
was a huge benefit in the game it was
and I would like other teams to watch
this as a possible blueprint right cloud
the middle
don't let the easy throws happen the
worst third and long right they
disciplined on trick play change the
looks upfront make their old line
communicate you know Brady was rushed
watching the rush a little yesterday
it's one of the it's one of the most
I've ever seen him to where he was
concerned his eyes left downfield I'm
not saying him as like Eli Manning
watching the rush but there was a few
player I was going damn look at him he's
peaked down at the rush well he was
under attack he was under attack right I
know but I'm just saying cuz he's
usually so fearless and I could tell
with this decision-making and even when
there was a clean pocket it was a quick
look at the line one more time before he
threw it because he there had been
people around him he just wanted to make
sure so you think it's hit sack fumble
all that it also looked to me that they
really need Sony Michelle to be full
strength they do they needed a run game
to make all that stuff work and they
need Shaq Mason yes Zack Mason is one of
the best guards in football if Belichick
gives you a long-term deal and a lot of
money of the offensive line yeah you
know you're a baller right as everybody
else can be replaced exactly right all
right let's move on to lions and bears
and what we got on the internet
yesterday was not big Phil we got big
[ __ ] sitting there with old
argumentative Adam shine tell you
something about your best game just such
a New Yorker to the core right but big
Phil when you and big Phil get angry
you're the same person Mitch Wilshire
Biscay people tell me who threw the ball
do feel good and then he looks at shiny
goes at sarcasm and he stood up furture
Biscay
yeah and sure Biscay rewarded him almost
immediately
nurse Lee Travis keys deep balls to Alan
Robinson we're looking great yeah he
threw some some smart slants
some of his running I'm talking I think
he's the best mobile quarterback in the
NFL fqo I think you got a said I mean I
I've rolled it down I think in the notes
I wrote a question mark I said best
runner in the NFL QB I mean it's between
him romantics
well no I'm with you though I mean him
cam to show John Watson yeah who is it
who else would battle him in that
conversation that's about the Holmes is
not know mahomes was mobile Russell
Wilson yeah right so it's those four I
think those four are and then Aaron
Rodgers if he's healthy right but I'm
not even gonna say he's a good just
flat-out runner they aren't like though
these guys can escape the pocket and if
there's a lane they can run for 30 yards
but I think out of all of them that try
Biscay might be the most elusive yeah he
breaks legitimate tackles and then keeps
weaving and out if he does I know I
think Russell Wilson is the most aware
Russell Wilson why I appreciate him so
much yeah he's he's the ultimate looks
like he's going out of bounds and gets
four more yards and stretches over for a
first down right like he's so good at
that cam is the most powerful yeah and
Watson I think is the longest stride
danger yeah right Watson has a little of
all of them like the Russell and true
Biscay combination yeah yeah but yeah
either way it just it's fascinating what
he does it's a real weapon and it bails
him out of the game or bails him out of
some big situations every week you have
been defending true Biscay with one
simple notion for a very long time yeah
he is a second-year quarterback in his
second offense right slow you're right
and a lot of people and understandably
so after how he looked against Seattle
and after how he looked against Green
Bay in the second half yeah when the
scripted plays went away do you want see
see see it's not that good and I feel
like people talk about him the way they
talk about Tannehill oh he's an athlete
right but we're starting to see the
pieces coming together and he really
does remind me of year two Carson Wentz
yeah I hear you
I know what you mean and I think that's
a good comparison I don't think he's
overall as talent as Carson else but I
know what you mean and a guy that we're
figuring out the offense right now is
relying on his physical tools that were
come the complications that he doesn't
know no doubt he's kind of in a mix of
both things where he's leaving his
weapons I know the weapons are special
his ability you know yeah
again is it's a second year in the
offense and the other thing that needs
to be talked about that I think is
adding to this is to because of two guys
and two guys alone Watson in my homes
they've added to this like they're
awesome and our guys not awesome yet
what's wrong
well okay yeah they have more talent
around them I mean Patrick mahomes got
lucky than a team that's a playoff team
traded for him so he's got to get that
benefit and you know I think Holmes is
the man right you know Watson same type
of thing kind of a playoff team they had
a bunch of injuries that year and they
got to make it pick for him at 11 or 12
or whatever it was so they were
fortunate to fall that he went to a team
that was in a to true rebuild true right
third pick in the draft and second
system like you said in second year he's
got all these new coaches around him all
these new players around him he's
getting used to everything around him he
has talent and now he has weapons around
him and it's it's a good combo the other
thing about Travis key is I think it's
like a human Road is that I think it is
Lombardi and I'm not talking all about
risky but he always talks about building
a starting 5 basketball team out of your
receivers I think the Bears may have
done it the best it's it's up there you
know yeah you got Allen Robinson that's
your big guy that can go up you got
Trabert and that could be your four you
got to wreak CONUS your point guard yeah
you got Anthony Miller as your two
shooting guard and you got Gabriel you
got Gabriel you got Jordan Howard too
all those guys fit each other so yeah
yeah Adam Sheheen's coming back he's
another big option that you could throw
to another they got the Mosel kid who I
told you about last week he's been in
there now he's kind of doing Tariq own
stuff so I mean it's just a matter of
time before you see him catch a big play
you think they have a top-five ounce of
an offensive line even without Kyle I do
I think their offensive line is really
damn good they have they have everything
on offense they were very impressive
with what they did yesterday and that
was the best Allen Robinson looked to
this point this year and I don't give a
damn about the stats I'm talking just
about the way he caught balls and how he
looked when he tucked it away and
exploded to run down the field or his
first step off the line of scrimmage to
get off press bail and run by people all
was
best I've seen yes so you saw the Bears
exposing the cone the cone yeah I the
way this is I like the phrase expose the
cone expose the cone so if we're
watching football on TV right and we see
a bunch formation on the right with
three wide receivers yes and we see one
corner kind of lined up on that top guy
and two guys back expose the cone expose
the cone like you know the wide open
pass to Anthony Miller he has a little
flag wide open that was the cone they
expose the cone again the cone is three
on three right but the guy on the point
of the cone covering the guy in the
pointed cone that's man-to-man and then
the other two guys go I got the first
guy inside I got the first guy outside
well what they did on that play was they
said we'll send two guys outside they
sent the first guy outside and now he's
outside so the outside that gets him
right but now the other guy is also
gonna go outside but he goes vertical
and then outside so the guy outside is
going wait I already have my guy an
inside guy you better hurry up and catch
cuz that guy's running vertical and he's
gonna run outside too so I feel bad for
Beldar that Beldar what is Beldar Oh
Coneheads you're right I suppose the
compose the cow I'm just gonna think of
naked beldad that's what they did and
then after that after those two plays
really they got out of the cone and they
went to box a bunch that's what they did
because that's the next job your cone
gets exposed to your box must be bunched
you gotta box the bunch you know where
we are but yes the boxing the bunch is
basically making four guys a negotiation
right - now pass off the three man
combinations that they're using and
that's what all three guys go out well
you get that three on two yeah then the
guy inside is going to have to know when
he sees a third guy go out the inside a
third guy he's gonna have to press out
there and get there but yeah there's
little things you can do that it's the
chess game within the chess game and
then the other thing they did that
really exposed them in the past game is
they just found where number 26 was -
Shawn she'd whoever he was covering that
came from cm was open I mean it didn't
matter he couldn't cover anybody they
put him in situations ik man-to-man
against Alan Robbie that was a huge
issue they could not cover they could
not match up across the board with the
Chicago bear weapons when they wanted to
play man-to-man that was a big issue
Chicago Bear Dee
not only our is when I watched Khalil
Mack do they get after it not only are
they one of the league leaders I believe
in interceptions yeah they're a solid
unit with Vic Fangio is this bears
offense from what you saw yeah good
enough to not just get them in the
playoffs which they're poised to do
right now yeah but to maybe surprised
some people yeah I would not be some
that's good enough a hundred percent
there you know again when you look at
their offense
there's no glaring weakness as long as
you're sure Biscay is being consistent
throwing the football that's the only
thing that's been questioned at this
point just you'd like a little more
consistency on some of the throws other
than that there's nobody gonna overpower
them upfront their scheme is creative
and they find ways to get their
playmakers the ball you can't play them
man-to-man
they can run the ball you know
everything about them says they can they
can really match up with anybody and of
course we know their defense is really
awesome too and nobody's in the
steamroll that bunch so there's there's
no matchup that they're gonna go on the
field and go oh we're screwed today you
know the big thing that these offenses
share yeah the Rams the Saints the Bears
the Chiefs all of their quarterbacks
tected really well yes yes all have good
offensive line right have to worry about
the run game you know yes all that is
really the big issue is a big issue it's
it's like we always talk with great
offenses they make you defend the whole
field and that's what the Bears do is
there anything else before we kind of
move on that you want to touch on the I
was gonna bring up our man the Mensch
tarik cohen yep he's amazing to kill it
he's killing it he got drilled by
quandry digs that was a good one
paint the picture for everybody what
happened Josh I mean he's got the ball
on the left edge there was it was a
screen pass I believe Ike it was a short
pass either way he's got it he's flying
up the left side like kind of coming
through traffic and quandary digs Texas
hook em horns I mean he comes in like a
missile and puts his head and shoulder
right into the mensches chestplate yeah
and that knocked the wind out of him
big-time so he did yeah here's what
Tariq oh but he got up kind of quick
yeah he did he'd sucked it up he crashed
over for a minute you could tell he's
pointing to his chest like yeah you know
my [ __ ] hurts he said afterwards
I was not gonna give the Lions
satisfaction of me getting escorted off
the field I just lost my win he hit me
it was a good hit much respect to him he
knocked the wind out of me yeah but
that's my man
yeah the Mensch other men so you do you
get up you get up don't let him show and
he keep fighting Lahiya mention hi I'm
other thing too the last thing I'll say
first the no pass rush for the Lions
it's an issue that's one of their
biggest issues like they can also play
yeah he did but sparingly nothing and
that's where qu Brisky was able to take
over in a few big moments right the
other thing though that they did this
makes me think they're listening the
podcast the two big [ __ ] in the
middle started finally yeah that run
game mouth shot no hey Shawn hey Shawn
Robinson and that run game was
non-existent because of those two big
[ __ ] in the middle I mean they had
that wood that was it I love that you
took credit for them playing I don't
know what's so good so long I mean a
Sean Robertson finally just started over
the last few weeks that's the question
but what the hell's been happening
between Patricia and a Shawn Wright it's
a guy this is going back to the
preseason back to week one yeah you're
right I don't know what it is I know I
don't know if we'll ever know but that
gives them a chance because now they
don't have to at least put other guys in
to stop the run rs guitar and our DMS
asked with Robinson Gabriel and Miller
do the Bears have a top five wide
receiver room I believe they do I'm
gonna just quickly go over this top well
let's let's see
I mean who we're talking about here by
like our begin account Pittsburgh is a
top five receiving room just cuz of two
guys cuz I'm really knows the third well
if they're gonna call Trabert and then I
get to count Vance McDonald oh right you
should exactly right because Vance
McDonald also think James Connor counts
so your guy out to reek : okay so we
were gonna go purely Ryan beavers you
know what I gotta do Sims yeah pull the
team yeah if you're gonna do the pulley
the receivers Kansas City's obviously in
that question okay answer the Chargers
are in that question answered right okay
the Rams are in that question-answer and
I the Falcons are in that
question-answer right
and then it goes to like teams like I
think we're talking I think yes Chicago
Bears are the other team in that
conversation
I think the Giants are in there oh yeah
okay but we're still only talking about
to see I think the other teams we think
of in that conversation recent Minnesota
and goes to - are we gonna count laQuan
Treadwell is an awesome third now I mean
I think he's pretty good he's solid he's
mean he's finally a contributing your
you love depth well I'm just when you
say a wide receiver room that's more
than 2 to 3 people I got one
you know Carolina Carolina's close their
teetering in today got a bunch of guys
that I'm scared of it yes you know I
would say Tampa Bay Oh without question
Mike Evans DeSean Jackson Chris Godwin
and the the wiggle room freeze room
we're go for the bears are definitely
top five okay
yes now if we're just going for top two
duo's or top three trios then it's a
different conversation and it's a
different conversation if it's the top
ten rooms that we actually want to be in
I would want to be in that room that's
probably a cool room Tampa Bay or no
even Chicago I mean those are that's
that's we got a friendly they make us
they didn't deer us to everybody yes
all right now to the game that
apparently you and I were both watching
the most intently Jaguars cult's the
first thing that I want to bring up is
the quittin Nelson clip that's on line
of him screaming around the side and
destroying was it barrier Church alright
so let me find this one I just I'm just
gonna play the sound make your time of
my main man quit Nelson who I got a
chance to meet him and I went I went I
guess all off of an offensive guards are
this big and then I was talking to
Derwin James and ro Quan Smith and they
go I've never seen a human and then you
were like this guy's enormous but this
is the sound of Quentin Nelson coming
around the edge
[Music]
hey Quinn what's up man ah one is this
normal
no okay so I I thought I was like I
guess I'll pulling guards just yell as
they come around because they don't know
when the contact he's a psycho in a good
way he's a psycho he is he's I yelled
like I only yell that loud when the
lights are off and I'm and I'm at like
my parents house and I'm afraid of the
dark and like so I go down the stairs
and just like ah I don't like maybe I'll
scare the ghosts maybe you'll scare that
guy with the pipe that's hiding behind
okay so I thought you know maybe Quinton
was scared coming around the that's
probably part of that it's scared it's
aggression it's everything because he
didn't really hit buried church buried
Church ran into him kind of hot destroy
destroyed but that's not normal that odd
no not with any guard I ever played with
okay he's a different breed though this
is a you know I told Josh this earlier
you know I might break down an old lime
in there cows okay and deal I'm in her
bowls right there Bulls are on Rainer
I'm gonna swing my horns and I'm always
the cows like if we stay together we can
handle these Bulls right if we just
stand over here and eat grass nobody
will know we're here and we don't ever
have to work or walk anywhere ever like
that's a cow
he is a bull trapped in a cow body
that's what he is he's a D lineman
trapped in an alignment exactly right
and that's the difference between him
and that's what makes him great he how
do you see that and come up with that
conclusion because a psycho crap like
that like me watching him on the field
at Notre Dame last year and seeing the
absolute joy he got of just driving
people into the ground or blocking
people to the whistle I hear these
things all the time yeah where do you
see the joy I see the joy just because
it never ends and it's just but like
when you see joy like you see him coming
up and like smiling not getting a silent
smiling but coming up and you know chest
is pumped and it's bumped out like yeah
I just knocked your butt off again like
I know that you said that he was a
generational talent yeah you got to
watch him at Notre Dame yeah
what was it could you tell like right
away yes I could I I know we've talked
about this on this podcast before the
one of the first interview on estate
yeah well it's one of the first
interviews I ever did for Notre Dame or
anything associated with it and I just
watched their film and I'm getting a
feel for their team because I'm going to
him I gotta watch Notre Dame and get it
and everyone's telling me Mike
McGlinchey is gonna be a top ten pick
Mike Malinin I'm going damn I don't the
guy he might be but the guy next to him
is better the guy next to him is
unbelievable he does not miss a block
and he is like a tractor-trailer in the
run game
are there any other noises that us
regular football fans don't know about
that the microphones don't take up well
you might think I hear Jared Goff saying
Halle Berry and used to say jello and
Omaha Omaha Halle Berry is one of our
he's I got to go back and see the Halle
Berry play I'm guessing he ran a weak
side run 96 or 97 Wanda Wanda is kind of
a girl's name so we stole Halle Berry
and gentleman said Halle Berry I used to
have Ally Berry in my repertoire yes
Halle Berry Jennifer at 196 so you'd go
Halle Berry Los Angeles that means we
were gonna run Wanda to the left right
you know Halle Berry New York mint we're
gonna run Wanda to the right but we
always had two or three Jennifer Aniston
the same thing same play just a girl
that we added for Wanda JLo came in for
the bubble screen cuz she had a bubble
butt so he said well throw the bubble
screen
you know Tyson and rocker was dummy
because they were dummies in real life
Mike Tyson and John Rocker so they were
our dummy snap count thing with her are
there any other noises though that we
don't know about I'm not a lot of
yelling
linebackers can yell when they blitz
every now and then or like a safe to use
coming from depth and also you snap it
I've have a few it says right yeah like
they're coming or fullback and
linebackers who've been talking about it
they will yell at each other on like an
I so play that I've been talking crap
and they're like I'm covering again I'm
covered again the full-back is just a
set hut he's like they're psychos they
are psychos okay that's the part of
football that I simultaneously love and
I'm completely afraid yes it's scary
it's scary that to humans that if they
sat in here all I would talk about is
how large they are are going somebody
just tore their ACL or their Achilles
have you heard that was there any noise
that ever just remembers like the
weirdest noise you ever heard a football
field no I mean it stole that we were
just noises I ever heard on the football
field is Ray Lewis dancing over the ball
like so unscared of our team and so in a
happy place that I was like oh my gosh
we can't possibly beat these guys last
season the Colts gave up 12 sacks to
Jacksonville in one game yeah
yesterday they allowed zero quarterback
hits yeah hits I know dude the Colts
have not let up a sack in four games
right I said before the this game the
Jacksonville Jaguars were gonna get off
the Colts had only played the bills and
the Raiders the last few weeks I didn't
matter how good is this Colts offensive
line
I wanna start there yeah it's it's it's
extremely good I mean it has the
potential to be the best offensive line
in football
I mean it's three first-round picks
right am i right is Costanzo a
first-round pick or was he an early
second-round pick he believed he was a
first one but you keep talking I'm gonna
check but you got a guy like Quinn
Nelson who's top six pick you got you
know at he's that guard you got Kelly at
the center right Kelly was a he was
first was a first row so Kelly's a first
round Center yes you got Costanza left
this left guard Braden Smith's the
second round right tackle and then they
got glue in ski in there who's been a
solid and tackle Costanzo Costanzo right
so yes they have the potential to be one
of the top lines in football if not
they're already in that combo whether
you want to make a five or six or four
whatever it is they're there in that
that category Chris Ballard Ballard
kicking butt quit kicking butt and then
of course the owner - we got to give him
you know hey it's about protecting
Andrew we got to protect Andrew hey I
look man I I know Anthony moon Yost man
he was a hall-of-famer man and you're
right up to that level Quinn I mean he
must have been in that box yesterday in
that first half going so happy I signed
Eric Ebron yeah three touches yeah quit
Nelson and Eric Ebron man oh yeah isn't
it great to see healthy Andrew Luck it's
I hope he's reminding everybody that he
is one of the best quarterbacks on film
telling you guys the Colts are the are
the ultimate NFL ready shantia they are
the team to watch they are the most fun
to watch
alright Colts on that Jaguars defense do
you have like breaking news from your
son oh I have I've you know I text my
wife throughout the day of games to so I
have my notes I've said in you but that
as I'm watching the games I write little
notes I'm just trying to remind myself a
certain thing I just want to know how
did they tear up that Jacksonville
defense so hard well first first thing
is the old line like you said the pass
rusher was non-existent it doesn't
matter it just doesn't matter against
that that offensive line and it's right
I couldn't put a lot of money on the
Jags and our betting thing cuz that's
what scared me I just kept going they
might not be able to get there and an
old number 12 can sit there all day I
don't care how good your secondary is so
good he is so good so that's the big
thing
the first thing gosh they really exposed
Jacksonville with a few of their rules
and things that they do in certain
situations and Jacksonville blew some
coverages let alone asking sometimes
their guys to do unrealistic things and
once again which they do but I think
that's the biggest issue you know hey
the first touchdown for Eric Ebron right
he catches the corner route and nobody's
covering him well
what gave Jacksonville a lot of problems
is free releasing five receivers the
five eligibles not keeping the backend
right the back didn't Kate stay in - oh
let me chip this guy or maybe they bring
one backer and I'm gonna stay in no they
would get three out two aside and on the
first play of the game or that first
long pass to Erik ebon for the first
touchdown
you know they got caught I believe it's
buried church or yeah it's buried Church
or telling scorner so not yet okay so
now this one and only start back from
scratch this one is manda man okay I got
all my touchdowns I gotta figure them
out my head
this one is manda man and Jalen Ramsay
is man up auntie why Hilton the tight
ends to his side as well and also the
the back is offset to that side as well
so it's basically gonna be three on
three
and now Jalen Ramsey's man to man on
Hilton Church is gonna take the first
guy to the flat which ends up being the
back going to the flat tell Vaughn Smith
has to now take the vertical tight end
he doesn't take him so he gets confused
with how it's gonna be pass up it's
almost like owning the bunch a little
bit but it's a different way of talking
about it yeah and yes Ebron split split
the coverage and there's nobody there to
cover him wide open
you wrote the speed sweep to Ibrahim was
brilliant well the two-point converged
or the the fourth or third and one
whatever for that touchdown
that was a touchdown that was phenomenal
yes because they just they made
Jacksonville pause it's not easy to just
to run right up the middle on
Jacksonville in those situations I think
yesterday made me realize something yeah
and I'm not happy that I'm realizing
yeah there were three minds in the room
for Philadelphia last year with that
offense yeah right an offense that
confused the NFL a heavy tight end
package offense the obvious running
backs and wide receivers and a
quarterback that could do a little bit
of RPO but it was mainly based on good
ball plays right John Dee Filippo
now The OC of the Vikings Doug Peterson
still the head coach of the Eagles yeah
and Frank Reich now the head coach of
the Colts yeah of the Vikings the Colts
and the Eagles the offense that most
resembles the Eagles offense last year
yeah is the Colton Frank Reich right
they resemble it the most Jack Doyle and
Eric Ebron the quarterback movement
getting Nayeem Hines and Marlon Mac
involved in the passing game I think the
passing game was a step above your
passing game in Philadelphia right now I
think Frank Reich it's easy to say he
was the most creative pass game designer
there it's making me realize that maybe
Frank Reich was the secret sauce of the
Eagles offense last year
and I'd like to say to one person hmm
josh mcdaniels I hate you because if you
took that job the Eagles would still
have Frank Reich and none of this would
be happening so I hate you I don't like
that yeah it does it does feel like that
yes I mean Jaguars I feel like turned it
around the second half though they did
but not really you kind of mentioned it
there was the deflection off the tight
end that tell Vince Smith picked off I
mean I hit him in the chest first and 20
now him Hinds does an angle route he's
gonna run for at least 20 25 30 lead to
a quick punt right know that yeah the
Colts just the culture a team that if
their tight ends and it they just drop
easy passes sometimes they're not a
polished winner yet no they're not but
they have a lot of good pieces but they
shoot themselves in the foot all that do
they do that without a doubt that you
know Jacksonville kind of got back to
what they want to do on offense inside
of the ball in the third quarter I mean
they went on a 17 play drive that took
eight and a half minutes yes you know so
that kept Andrew lucking company off the
field it was good have Leonard Maltin
missed a field goal jagneauxs need to
run six screens a game I think they ran
two yeah but they ran they need to run
like six that's where they're passing
often I mean it's it's over it's like
the same thing we say every week it's
it's a crossing route a shallow crosser
a deep crosser and screens to the
backfield a lot of your notes are about
assignments and ways they took advantage
yeah I'd like to ask you a 30,000 feet
question right the Colts are now sitting
there in an AFC South yeah battling with
the Titans in the Texan right is this a
team that could make a playoff push down
the stretch or are they a year away I
think they're a year away okay I think
they can make a lot of games interesting
and they'll compete so they're gonna
leave here with a seven and nine eight
and eight record and we're gonna go look
out for the Colts vision they can add a
guy in the secondary and now the pass
another pass rusher things like that
their defense is still an issue for that
football team overall the offense really
has just about everything except they
can probably use one more receiver if
they had one
just legitimate receiver grant this
their right right if they can have one
work out of the mix they're they're
gonna be really hard to stop on that
side of the ball cuz the offensive line
is only gonna get better you talked
about Frank Reich and the creativity he
has hey they did think they took
advantage of Jacksonville rules there
over aggression you know remember the
one time Jack Doyle's the full-back he
comes out of the backfield he acts like
he's they're gonna run I so he's in a
blocked Elvin Smith and he runs right by
and runs a flag route you know they took
advantage of knowing the defense they
were in in a few times and Frank Reich
ticket to watch the Eagles in London
exactly right I know exactly how they
handle those plays then let's mix it up
exactly right that's another thing I'm
just happy I got the push so I did think
Jacksonville had a chance there a
receiver fumble at the end yeah cuz they
were moving they were they were kind of
unstoppable
it's all dump downs to hide and dump
down so Yeldon and get teams to let them
have it yeah because teams like the
Colts have to because they can't play
man-to-man or leave their corners in a
spot so they have to take my I won't
play Blake bortles and dak Prescott the
same way if you really think that Blake
bortles can throw a 40-yard pass over my
guy in man-to-man then we're gonna lose
I hear you got to take a few chances
there's quarterbacks like that no doubt
about it because the dump downs to the
running backs is what they want to do
yes all right can we go to the Browns
offense there was anything else no a lot
of rule violate it was a lot of rule and
violation a lot of those not a cat's
byali Cox though in the end zone I don't
know about that I don't know if I
totally agree with you there even though
ball moved I still think he had control
of it but either way it was definitely
dicey I hear he had Andrew Siciliano
both come let me just see what was the
other thing that I just thought was
interesting from that game oh you know
just sometimes to just unrealistic
things you know hey one thing that
Jacksonville does they get in the 13
personnel the Colts it's three tight
ends to the right
they put jaylen Ramsey at safety and now
Barrett basically Barry Church has to
play corner I understand why they do
that right because there's three tight
ends over there let's have a guy that
can actually stop the run if it comes
over there and now put jaylen Ramsey
let's use him as the speed safety guy
well they said fine that's fine with us
go ahead do that we're gonna pet we're
gonna test how Barry church plays corner
then and that was smart
again just little things
like that as far as figuring matchups up
and going let's make a guy feel
uncomfortable doing something he
shouldn't feel comfortable doing and
that's good coaching that's where I
gotta give Frank Wright credit also
realizing some of the rules you know
Jacksonville a little bit like we talked
about with Denver and I'll move on after
this yeah
is this like you can't have miles jack
be responsible for the backside C gap
and then also think he can cover T Y
Hilton man-to-man on a deep deep crosser
that's not fair - its miles Jackson will
look like he got beat by T Y Hilton on a
deep cross it's like when I'm watching
the Eagles cave and I'm like oh yeah
Dallas got our blocking - Marcus Lauren
right yeah right cool all right
I'm gonna hold off on the Browns offense
I'm gonna save that for Wednesday yeah
and so farewell out there that's
wondering about man Baker Mayfield in
this last two games five touchdowns one
interception 118 passer rating and Nick
Chubb all of a sudden averaging 6.2
yards per carry we're gonna dig into
that a little bit I want to get to some
news and stuff okay cool Le'Veon Bell
and apparently it's not gonna report at
all right it looks like we're going
through the whole year without levy on
I'm sad I wanted the ten weeks but I
guess that he's gonna get paid like a
quarterback no matter what if they
franchise tag them I'm a little bit
surprised are you surprised I am
surprised I'm saddened I don't think
it's the right move for Le'Veon I don't
I don't think him sitting out a whole
year is good for him in his career I
don't and also I don't think it's gonna
help him maximize what he wants and free
agency I'm gonna be tough I'd I mean I
think the the point of him doing what he
was doing was to save his body you're on
a playoff team and then you could come
in and play really well to where
everybody could see what you could do on
a playoff team and then instead of
getting X guaranteed dollars you got X
plus a little bit more because you were
awesome down the stretch I'm taking a
year off from football lefke was not
easy Steelers kick the crap out of the
Panthers yeah I'm still watching that
game and I'm going James Connor is not a
top-five back he's not a top-10 back and
I'm okay to argue that with anybody
me and Josh were sitting there watching
the game Thursday night at SRI ona's on
3rd and I'm sitting there I'm going I
think people forget how good levian is
and I brought up some levee on
highlights that I showed Josh and he
goes James Connors never done that no
never no it's just another level
Troy Aikman tried to say it during the
math story he tried to say it like hey
James Conner is really good but he's not
loving oh but nobody wants to listen
because everybody else is an expert now
everybody levy on people found his tweet
from 2013 if you could sit out a year of
a sport you play you're not injured or
you're preventing anything then you
don't love it I think if anything it
makes me more confident levy on that
unless you're going through it you can't
comment on it that's right levy ons
trying to get paid he wants a large
guaranteed check that's what he wants so
all the ones saying you gave up fifteen
million dollars levy on is trying to get
out of the rat race of playing year to
year yeah he wants probably a three or
four year deal with any we're probably
between forty and fifty million dollars
guaranteed and he's thinking you know
what once that's guaranteed it'll cover
everything yeah if he gets it then he's
won right if he doesn't then he's lost
yes but you can't really comment on it
Steelers Panthers there's one thing I
learned from that game yeah stop putting
good football on Thursday 90 left sucks
yes it sucks I know Panthers were
destroyed they were like they weren't
themselves Sean Payton Saints Bengals
you nailed this one you didn't nail
Falcons Browns now this one Sean Payton
before the game Sims told Diana Rossini
that he was worried that his team wasn't
gonna show up to play yeah he said he
got in there a few hours before the game
and he saw some of his guys eating
pancakes and he went No
and he smashed the fire alarm and yelled
at the top of his ass he did I heard
about the fire came in yelling like a
maniac and smashed the fire alarm you
said this when we were picking the game
Sean Payton knows that his team is on a
mission yeah I love that he smashed the
fire yeah but that's what it takes
cuz you knew didn't smash the fire alarm
Dan Quinn you know what apparently Devon
dree Campbell said about the team Devon
Drake Campbell said about the team I'm
trying to find it just him Josh is
messing with my run down here
he said that all week we were sitting
there going it's gonna be fine we're
playing the Browns we'll figure it out
Yeah right that they were actively
saying that right Sean Payton knew that
I'm destroying the fire right Sean
Payton I think is up there for coach of
thee yeah he is I mean he's he's just
he's one of the greatest coaches we've
seen in modern history III that's how
strongly I feel about Sean Payton you
know listen he's not been a guy that has
been in control of the roster the whole
time so yeah it's gotten away from the
Saints at times and then of course he
had a deal with you know you know what
was it head gator well you know County
game right he had a deal with that so he
missed a year of football there that
hurt the football team but yes that's
what great coaches do they keep their
team on edge at all times that's what
makes balichek special and it's what
gives them the type of edge to go out
there and just smash a team like like
the bangles the falcons thing I mean
that's funny you're saying that because
I mean one of the first things I wrote
for my notes was Falcons screwed up a
lot their offense screwed up a lot they
did not come to play they were not
detail so if Matt Ryan was cursing up a
storm
holy cow I mean some new fumbling yes
more than one from the third and one
from the one-inch line and they run a QB
sneak and it's off size on Cleveland and
they don't run the QB sneak the next
play and run it up the middle and then
it's still fourth than one from the inch
line and they decide to throw a pass on
fourth down and don't score their ball
gets snapped over the head of Matt Ryan
one time like they just they didn't they
look like the team that wasn't ready to
play weren't ready to play right the
other thing was Saints Bengals Terrell
Austin fire today
yeah in the last four games the Bengals
have allowed 20 117 yards the most over
a four-game stretch
ever the Bengals defense just got
destroyed now they didn't have dark as
Denard vantaa is perfect a number of
guys but yeah the Bengals have and the
fact that they're stole the playoff race
is crazy
yeah succeed for the AFC playoffs is
very underwhelming it's a bunch of teams
that I don't really care about but the
Saints I'm watching that game people are
going I'll tell you what yeah drew Brees
he's gonna win the MVP over Patrick
mahomes the way they're going I go if
you'll watch the game screen to Kamara
runs 450 screened to Ingram runs 451
plant to Thomas runs 4:30 do you see why
I don't have Thomas as a top-10 receiver
do you see it I don't think you have to
agree but you understand yes where I'm
coming from my issue is this and I
appreciate everyone that whenever
someone comments now that Drew Brees is
gonna be MVP yeah and they send me it I
appreciate it yeah it really is wild to
go that everyone looks at the statistic
right and everyone looks at the records
and then everyone looks at how it works
and how he manages the game but no one's
looking at the throws no one's sitting
back and going what is this team asking
him to do right you know mahomes is lace
and 40-yard laser beams in between
people right drew brees would never
throw it this is not the Good Samaritan
Good Samaritan of the Year award this is
not the Lifetime Achievement Award you
don't get the MVP cuz oh he's never won
one and we should just give it to him
the only thing that he needs to fill up
his trophy case as an MVP no one is owed
anything if he wins MVP you know the way
guaranteed contract yeah no one is owed
anything yeah I know I don't know what
else to say man if Patrick mahomes
throws 50 touchdowns and Drew Brees wins
MVP yeah not out of your mind it means
that the officially that the media has
to stop voting for MVP and stuff like
that people also forget what the
expectations were for these teams before
the year right people were saying
including me that the Chiefs were gonna
be a six win team a five win team the
Saints were been picked to go or the
Super Bowl I picked him to win it yeah I
know I don't know okay Cooper Cup
tourneys yeah yeah I know that stinks I
gotta think it was like almost partially
torn from his just non getting hurt a
few a few weeks ago against denno big of
a deal is that for a Rams team that
those three weapons at wide receiver
were such a big part of their ya know
it's a big deal it certainly is I mean
they're a team that you know first of
all they live in what we call 11
personnel I don't know Tony Romo made so
many good points yesterday right he said
look they live an 11 personnel they do
he goes and that Shawn McVeigh wants to
do he's going to show you the same thing
all game and just do a million variation
exactly right that's and so an 11
personnel one tight end one running back
typically 3 wider see it's Cooper cup
Robert Woods Brandon cooks right and
then you see one of those receivers run
the fake speed sweep or whatever it may
be they do a million different things
off of that yeah yes and it's not the
most complicated thing Keenan rounds is
pretty good Reynolds is good he's not
burka no he's not Cooper Cup and then
they got to do it with you know some of
their tight end Plato they're gonna have
to do it with those two guys where
they're freaked out they are too so they
you know you might see Jarrell Everett
in the game a whole lot more as a slot
receiver and go don't don't think Sean
Payton I mean Sean McVeigh can't do it
he came from a place in Washington where
he did have two tight ends a lot of
times Niles Paul and Jordan Reed and he
got a boast on the fall on the field at
the same time so he'll have plenty of
stuff in his repertoire even with it
with this this issue I'll tell you what
I don't think the Seahawks and Josh
Reynolds taking in too oh yeah I didn't
think that the Seahawks thought that
they'd play the Rams this year score
over 60 points in the two games combined
Russell Wilson play out of his mind yeah
the running game destroyed having
different 100-yard running backs and
they lose both games I know I didn't
think they thought that but I went that
game went exactly how I said it was
gonna go where Michael Dixon was able to
pin the Rams back a few times yeah
Seahawks got a few big breaks every now
and then but that game the Rams had
control of the entire time it wasn't
even a never a danger and certainly
wasn't you always felt like the Rams are
gonna be able to move the ball as soon
as they needed to and and that was that
and yeah again the running game for the
Seahawks certainly respectable the pass
games not scary enough it's still really
dependent on Russell Wilson making magic
with his legs and making unbelievable
throws can he play like that the whole
game and not just the last two four
minutes you know cuz I would like dak
yeah to play like Russell Wilson Bryce
in the last three minutes yeah yeah I
hear you it's just running is your
second option well it's hard to play
with that reckless abandon until you
have to because if you start start off
the game going okay I'm just gonna go
crazy out here and make plays happen
that's when your fumble early on or get
there one interception early on so
there's a time and place in the game
where he's been around long enough note
know when that time is but I bet you
early in his career he probably had
offensive coordinator P Carol go it's
time go that's let it loose a little bit
push the envelope start how to play
around 4.4 - yeah I'm Jerry I'm going
hey hey dang we don't know if we're
gonna extend you so these long-term
injury things are not really concerned
we want to maximize your potential right
now just run around you get hurt I
wanted to see this Cooper rushed now for
a few years well that's why they should
have more quarterback design runs I will
agree with you they did it against
Tennessee they did it they did the week
before that yeah
Chargers Raiders I think is of the three
four o'clock games that were all nine
and a half points spreads yeah I thought
the Rams were the clear best team in
their game right even though the
Seahawks kept it close because the Rams
defense has some issues I thought Green
Bay let the Dolphins hang around but you
knew they were gonna blow him out the
entire time Aaron Rodgers it was too
easy for him against that defense Aaron
Jones look good right
but those sneaky close game was Chargers
Raiders yeah this is a Raiders team that
failed on a fourth and goal on the one
Chargers got the goal line stand right
Raiders had the ball almost the entire
first quarter
then the Raiders drive down a few times
in the second half and just you know
Derek Carr was under attack right that
offensive line for the Raiders is a mess
race of math and the Chargers offense
Philip Rivers is great when you're
coming from behind but sometimes he's a
lunatic when you're playing with a lead
they played a protected game yesterday
and they're they wait for the Melvin
Gordon explosion to create the lead and
all that stuff but you got to remember
just don't forget just don't forget
that's sometimes during the week the
head coach is telling his team to be
like that right sometimes better team or
better we don't think they're gonna be
able to score mony more points Jared
cook these memories it was like it was
like monster it was like Jon Gruden went
to Jared cook and said hey if you don't
play well you're gonna play with me the
rest of your career
he said no I mean he's stiff talk he was
getting in fights with people yeah cheer
the quote after the game that's making
the
no one readers veteran said to another
one on the way out of the locker room I
gotta get the [ __ ] out of here mm-hmm
now the reporter he might have also been
saying you know I got my kids birthday
party but people are acting every
statement right now apparently when
Bruce Irvin got to Atlanta he came in
the practice field and said I'm free I'm
free
and then Mark Davis came out there today
and said put it on me we failed the
rebuild since 2014 which pretty much
means Reggie Mackenzie messed it up yeah
and I would like to say to mark Davis
you traded multiple picks for Carson
Palmer and Reggie McKenzie didn't have
picks and then he took you Khalil Mack
Derek Carr and Amari Cooper I do not
blame any of this I went to the playoffs
until I started off nine and one so do
not blame this on Reggie McKenna now
that seems like a total damage control
comment by the Davis family today that
he was coming out just to yeah kind of
save Gruden save the coaching staff
change the perception a little bit take
the heat himself which I do think some
of us probably on him to a degree they
do have money issues I don't think they
could pay Cola Mac the cold hard liquid
cash he was developing on Stadium and
they have a lot of issues so I don't
think it's all on Gruden but yeah today
that was a comment today to take some
pressure off the coaching and front
front off look they missed with the Karl
Josef's they missed with the Obon melon
Fondren who's they missed with a number
of you know hi Gary and Conley's
apparently Colt Miller doesn't look that
great hot words guy you know you got to
think about who's the other guy from far
to state who left oh the neck injury
Mario and Mario Edwards there's been a
lot there has been yeah yeah so that's
going on with the Raiders I got a fan
question for you from these Sims and
left go reddit what's up fam boy this is
that wasn't doctors a Rosen Duke you
bees throw a long toss like baseball
players to warm up each day that's the
first question
yeah not not a lot dude no Patrick
mahomes does you know cuz he's a
baseball player well yeah a little bit i
I would say that I would air on that
more times than not let me just throw
low dose not like the long toss but I
wasn't into staying five feet in front
of me
me rifle to your head whoa I'm awesome
at five feet away no it was just it was
it was I always started off with a good
15 20 yard lob let me just throw it out
there be relaxed create the opposites
like we talked about this is another one
that I'm excited to hear your answer
what was the max that you could throw Oh
like distance-wise
yeah I would you max bro 76 you hit that
one time yeah I could throw it like I
could always throw between 74 76 77
yards 76 was your long 76 was my long I
did that like maybe once or twice even
in practice in Tampa when I had to be
Michael Vick and stuff that was Brad
Johnson it's like my it's like I feel
like the first time I was like man Brad
thinks I'm kind of good because you're
just like I was running around and I
went I I got done with practice that
there was my rookie year and I had to be
Michael Vick and scouts team yeah but
you know was a disservice to Michael
Vick in our defense cuz I couldn't run
like him but I had to run around and do
that and launch balls all over the field
and I got done with practice I remember
Brad looked at me it was like you look
good out there today I was like oh cool
and then I we watched it we watched the
practice film and I threw a few of my
launches and I went back I always go
back and watch my scout team throws let
me see if there's something I did yeah
check my mechanics and a few of the
times after I threw balls
I could see Brad on the sidelines
counting the yards to see how far I
threw it and I was like Oh Brad's having
had a catch with me yeah what do you
think my long is and that laugh was John
you definitely can go over 40 okay I'm
gonna say you're somewhere in the 42 to
50 range I think your head it's solid I
don't think you could go more than 50 I
would probably say like 46 50 would be
incredible yeah I'm just thinking about
like when well I've you know if there's
always sounds like a number yeah then I
always think when you get on the
football field right and you realize how
far like a 50-yard field goal is it's
insane it is insane you also to just
throw at 50 and not have any consequence
for accuracy or wearing that's going
that changes things you know
quarterbacks gonna throw it 50 yards it
still hit the guy like right per week of
driving if it's like 6 feet out of
battery
right uh Josh how far can federic throw
it ah low 40s
of low 40s like maybe thirty nine ish
somewhere around there especially we're
using NFL balls there's no way he can
get over 45 so big yeah right okay so I
we actually might have to do that that
might actually be a worthwhile like
Instagram video I want to be pretty good
today my only other question coming off
of that fan question thank you again
doctors a Rossum was when you do that
voice where you went oh yeah I'm so cool
that your throws can you visualize that
character for me like what does that
character look like when you say that
because it's in your head I know I don't
know if I have a visually I don't have a
visual like visualizations of any
certain person saying it but when you're
like oh man there was a sick five your
throw what do they look like I just I'm
putting it to like it's it's like dumb
fanboy that's that's all it is I don't
know I have no color their hair I'm
actually thinking about quarterbacks
more than anything that used to do that
kind of stuff and I beg man that is
pointless what he's doing right thanks
which quarterback I used to watch Peyton
Manning come out and warm up to like
Reggie waiting don't get me wrong I mean
Peyton Manning's the man yeah he could
crap on me every day of the week in
seven seven or twice on Sunday but he
used to come out and pregame warmups and
he literally just throw it like five
feet in like Marvin Harrison and Reggie
Wayne he's just stand there and he big
like why what's the point like you know
you don't ever throw like that you're
never gonna make a throw like that
you're never just gonna like step into a
throw like that like you're like weren't
like it just there's no realistic part
of it but it's what made him feel good
and that's what he went with what was
the backup for the Browns and hard
knocks that got cut bro ban what was
this any broken bro yeah oh yeah Hogan
no Brogan no the one this year that got
cut it wasn't the one that was like
super dumb did they have the Hogan was
it broken
Road by gosh that's what I when you do
that voice that's who I think of broma
through a five your best being like
crazy
and high school kids like really good
dude yeah all right last one this is
from read a book in the JDM no I will
not read a book could Simms explain why
receivers will move in motion halfway
across the line then move right back
where they started the play okay is that
just to see what kind of coverage that
is it's all it's about so if somebody
runs with them they're in man if they
don't right also you're doing like
you're going also throughout the week
the offensive coordinator is going you
know when sometimes teams bring this
counter motion right that's what we'll
call it like the guy there's a tight end
to the right and a receiver to the right
and the the quarterbacks are bringing
the receiver to basically come to the
quarterback and then go back out there
testing the communication of the middle
linebacker and everything that's really
what are they're doing because at the
tight end at the receiver even in zone
coverage and you know it's it's zone
it's not man to man the corner stayed
there they're still going there's a lot
of defenses we'll still have oh wait now
with three receivers to the side we got
to make this call and get to this
coverage just to get them talk just to
get them talking and then also he goes
fashion it goes on we got to do this and
again you know you can get guys it's
it's happening fast middle linebackers
trying to process they're thinking a lot
of things through the week and although
there are any defenses that even though
they're playing the zone they'll run
with the corner to make it seem like
they're playing ma'am every now and then
yeah every now and then they have to be
like a really good defense well like we
saw we saw the the Patriots do that
against Aaron Rodgers I think I wrote
that in my notes like a few times they
brought the corners over to make it look
like man-to-man so they go here Aaron's
gonna go man it's man-to-man I'm gonna
get to my man-to-man play they're not
gonna stop it and then they played zone
and they did little things like that yes
a next-level quarterbacks and I see and
go there's gotta be man-to-man
my follow-up to that is if there's big
games yeah and these coaches put in
these super wrinkles when it's a big
game right is it too exhausting to do
that every week yes it can be yes yeah
and I think to what happens in the big
games a lot of the times as you start to
feel like you were weak in this area and
even though I might have to go out of my
comfort zone
here yeah I gotta push the envelope
against a brady and josh mcdaniels
i just figured every week they probably
should but as we've talked about nine
million times coaches or chicken crap
for most of the time and they're
conservative by nature yeah where they
just don't want to do a whole lot new
this is where i'm good at I want us to
be sounded everything I don't trust this
guy he got a low Wonderlic score
whatever it is there's so many things
that play and I'm gonna end the podcast
on this note as the season winds down
and a lot of the award season picks up
and we're debating breeze versus mahomes
and we're talking about Offensive Rookie
of the Year when it comes to coach of
the year and everyone's debating about
whether it's Andy Reid Sean McVeigh or
Sean Payton I think those will be the
three teams that get the most talked
don't forget about the team with three
wins
Sean McDermott yes sir sim said it
earlier I think it's a really good one
there in every game that they play
except for that first game against
Baltimore yeah and that one game against
Indy both games defined by Nathan
Peterman yeah the Colts was Derek
Anderson three days off the golf course
sorry so Derek Anderson and Nathan
Peterman I but every other game they're
in and he goes with Matt Barkley who was
three days off the golf course and they
drop a 41 spot on the Jets a fake punt
early in that game a touchdown throw to
an offensive guard and pretty much
signed sealed delivered the fate of one
of his rival division coaches after they
back-to-back years sold the entire team
blew it up yeah and her doing a drastic
rebuild traded Ronald Darby right got
rid of Corti Glenn traded arse out there
Marcell Darius Erik wood has a neck
injury this year Ritchie's comments off
the team yes I mean and all they do is
every single week that defense keeps
them in the game shuts down the offense
and they make it were number one defense
in football really the Buffalo Bills are
the number one defense in football
officially and did you hear that you
hear that you hear that you hear that I
mean yeah you're knocking on the table
okay I just want you to hear you know
what that is
you know what it is please tell me you
know this what it's the final nail in
Todd Bowles coffin it's officially
sealed whether it's today tomorrow next
week after the year it's done that ended
it so we can move on
no I when you get a touchdown scored on
you by Dion Dawkins and I meant it by a
team that like can barely score the
football and you're a defensive head
coach and the Buffalo Bills with Matt
Barkley score 41 on you yeah it's over
it's night-night time it's over but I do
like that you brought up the McDermott
thing he did not that he's going to win
it and we don't say [ __ ] but he should
be talked about in that he can always
win the Sims and left go coach of the
Year award he can I mean didn't the dude
was it was 9 to 6 with two minutes left
in the third quarter against the
Patriots I mean that's there just tells
you what he's about with Derrick
Anderson who late in the game was got
hit and said I'm done playing football
I'm concussed I'm out of here and I
don't even know if I'm concussed I just
don't want to be here all right
foursome peace out homies vendrick what
are you gonna say and for the lef koe
man I had the Monday afternoon of my
life and I owe it all to you see you
guys later
you